قررت نقابه النقل التابعه للاتحاد العام
التونسي للشغل الدخول في اضراب عامه يومي
الخامس والعشرين والسادس والعشرين من
يناير المقبل وتتهم النقابه الحكومه
التونسيه بالسعي لخصخصه مؤسسه النقل
العموميه بينما تنفي سلطات ذلك كانت
القيادات النقديه قد صعدت من الانتقاداتها
لسياسات الرئيس سعيد واستدعوات من
المعارضه للانتخابات الرئاسيه مبكرا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الاعزاء كندا حلقتنا
ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات على ماذا تؤشر
دعوه نقاده النقل في اتحاد الشغل لاضراب
عام في القطاع واستت تصاعد انتقاد
القيادات النقديه والسياسيه المعارضه
لاصرار الرئيس السيد علي المضيء في
سياساته
وما هي الحلول المطروحه للخروج من هذه
الازمه ومن بينها حديث اتحاد الشغل عن
خريطه طريق في ذلك الاتجاه امام مدى فرص
نجاح تلك الحلول بالنظر الى الانقسامات
داخل المعارضه ونهج الرئاسه التونسيه في
اداره شان العام
[موسيقى]
والى اين سينضل مشهد في بعدين السياسي
والاقتصاديه في ظل توقعات متشائمه بشان
حصول تونس على قرض من صندوق النقد الدولي
والمواقف الاقليميه والدوليه من كل ذلك
[موسيقى]
سواء تعلق على الامر بالمؤشرات السياسيه
او الاقتصاديه لا يجادل اثنان داخل وخارجه
تونس في ان البلاد تمر بازمه متفاقمه
استعصت الى حد الان على الحل
يعود في جانب منه لاختلاف بين النخل سواء
كانت في السلطه او المعارضه في تشخيصها
وكيفيه الخروج منها
بين هؤلاء وهؤلاء يحاول الاتحاد العام
التونسي للشغل الاحتفاظ بمسافه مع الجميع
ممددا بما وصلت اليه الامور وداعيا للبحث
عن خريطه طريق للخروج من عنق الزجاجه غير
ان الملاحظه مؤخرا هو تصاعد انتقادات
القيادات النقديه لسياسات الرئيس سعيد حيث
قالت ان الوضع بلغ درجه التعفن وان
الرئاسه لم تلتقط رساله عزوف التونسيين
المشهوده عن التصويت في الانتخابات
التشريعيه
في المقابل الرئيس سعيد يوصل على نهجه
مؤكدا ان التونسيين ماضون في مواعيد هم
الانتخابيه ومشددا على ان البلاد تحتاج
نوعا من ما سماه التصفيه السياسيه قائلا
ان التطاول على الدوله ورموزها ليس من
قبيل حريه التعبير بل يرتقي الى مستوى
المس بامنها وضرب وحدتها حسب قوله سعيد
اشار خلال لقائه مع رئيسه الحكومه نجلاء
بودن الى ان الديمقراطيه يجب ان تمارس
داخل مؤسسات الدوله ولا يمكن ان تكون
مواجهه ضد وجودها ووحدتها واضاف سعيد ان
من يلعب دور الضحيه اليوم هو من ضرب
الدوله وحاول بكل الطرق تفكيك مؤسساتها
وانه لا يمكن ان يقدم نفسه منقابا حسب
تعبير
[موسيقى]
بمناسبه هذا الموضوع معنى من سوسه شرقي
تونس قيصر الصياح المحامي والباحث في
القانون ومن تونس معنا صبري الزغيدي
الصحفي بجريده الشعب التابعه للاتحاد
العام التونسي للشغل وكذلك معنا رياض
الشعيبي ايضا من تونس عضو الهيئه
التنفيذيه لجبهه الخلاص وابدا مع السيد
صبري الزغيدي
سؤال سيد صبري عن
هذا الاضراب اضراب اييي نقابه النقل في
تونس
وماذا تعني الدعوه لهذا الاضراب في ضوء ما
تعيشه تونس من ازمات اكان اجتماعيه او حتى
سياسيه وتجاذب على كل المستويات
مساء الخير استاذ حسن
الاضراب بالنسبه للمناظمه الشغيله الاتحاد
العام التونسي الشغل ليس هدفا بل هو وسيله
يضطر اتخاذها وتضطر اتخاذها الهياكل
النقابيه للمنظمه الشديده من اجل على
الطرف الاخر يعني على الطرف الحكومي او
الاعراف
حتى ياتي الى طويله التفاوض والنقاش الجهد
ومن مسؤول يحيى الحلل المطالب المهنيه
والاجتماعيه العامه بالنسبه لقطاع النقل
قطاع النقل يعني منذ فتره طويله وهو يلوح
بالتصعيد وهو يدعو
الحكومي ووزاره النقل الى الجلوس من اجل
البحث في عموميه وديمه قطاع النقل هذا
القطاع الذي من المفروض ان ياكل قاتره
الاقتصاد الوطني وان يكون يعني
نعم نعم طيب نحن نحن لا نريد ان ندخل في
تفاصيل هذا الاضراب واسباب هذا الاضراب
بمعنى همم يعني همم فقط الجانب النقابي
والمطلب منه بقدر ما نريد ان نفهم الرساله
والمغزى من من هذا الاضراب وخصوصا ان
الرئيس سعيد نفى ان يكون هناك نيه
بخصخصه هذا القطاع وبالتالي ما هي الرساله
الموجهه الى سلطات الى الرئيس سعيد من
وراء هذا الاضراب لكن باختصار ارجوك
باختصار مطالب قطاع النقل واستحقاق مهني
واجتماعي
الحالي وقيس سعيد او حكم هذه المستحقات
لاعوال القطاع النقل
اي تحرك احتجاجتي اي قطاع وستاتي هناك
كفاحات اخرى سوف
اضراب مطلب سيد قيصر السياح الاضرار اضراب
همم مطلبي وياتي هذا الاضراب بعد همم
الانتخابات التي اجريت والتي كانت نسبه
المشاركه فيها هزيله جدا حتى المؤيدون
للرئيس سعيد واوصاته قالوا انها رساله
شعبيه
رساله عدم رضا عن الواقع المعيشي في
البلاد والان هذا الاضراب ايضا ربما يكون
في هذا السياق في سياق الاعتراض والرفض
للواق المعاش في تونس لماذا لا يلتقط
الرئيس سعيد هذه الاشارات وهذه الرسائل
ولماذا لا يتعامل بمنطق الحوار من اجل
الوصول الى حلول
ضيفيني اولانا خلافا لما
تفضل به ضيفك في خصوص الطرح الذي قدمه
والذي يتعلق بعدم رغبه الاتحاد في التشويش
على الوضع الاقتصادي والسياسي في البلاد
وخروجه
ووجوده بمنع عن كل هذا امر غير صحيح
باعتبار الاتحاد منذ اسبوعين تقريبا ويهدد
ويلوح بالاضراب العام والاضراب العام كما
تعرفون سواء على النقل تابعه لجامعه
الجامعه الوطنيه وغيره وهو شلل كامل
الاقتصاد الدوله والاتحاد يعرف يدرك جيدا
وهو منظمه كبيره وعملاقه في تونس ولا
تاريخها يدرك جيد ان اي اضراب في فتره هذه
جدا وفي منها عرج وفي وضعيه تعيش فيها
تونس انزلاقات سياسيه وانحدار اقتصادي لا
مثيل له منذ 30 سنه تقريبا ولا اتحاد يقوم
في هذا الضرب بالذات بعد الانتخابات وبعد
الترويح من المطالبه حوار وطني وهو الذي ق
ثلاث سنوات حوارات وطنيه وخريطه طريق
قرطاج واحد وخريطه طريق قرطاج 2 ولم تفلح
وتتني الينا باربع حكومات في ضرب 16 وهو
عار على سياسه التونسيه وعلى انه خبي تلك
الفتره الان الاتحاد عندما يتجاه المطلبيه
الضيقه في وضع اقتصادي في عجز بين عام ب
110,000 مليار وفي خلاف حتى لما سرحت به
الحكومه التونسيه همم
130% يعني احنا دخلنا الان في مرحله الخطر
القصوى تلاقي حتى الان عندما تكون رساله
بهذا الشكل بهذه الرساله لا يمكن رئيس
الدوله ان يلتقط رئيس الدوله نعلم ونكون
حياديين وموضعين رئيس الدوله يعني كيف
اقول مثلا مصري ناشفه يعني يرفض تماما اي
حوار ويعتقد ان الوضع الذي اتت به
الديمقراطيه العافيه
هو يوم اسود على القانون التونسي يعني
وجهه نظر الاتحاد طيب
فقدت في لحظه حكم الكلمه التي حل عن
التونسي شغل كان بامكانه ان يطالب به
مناهج اخرى للحوار ولم الشمل
والخروج عن المنطقه بتاع خريطه طريق
القديمه والتي لم تاتي بشيء الى تونس اتت
فقط بدمار وراينا نهايه السيد باجي
وهذا يطرح سؤال عن البدائل همم اسمح لي
هنا اسال السيد رياض الشعيبي في في هذه
النقطه سيد رياض هل تنظرون الى هذا
الاضراب وانت عضو الهيئه التنفيذيه لجره
الخلاص وهي الجبل المعارضه للرئيس قيس
سعيد هل تنظرون الى هذا الاضراب على انه
بدايه للتصعيد الذي سبق لجبات الخلاص ان
همم
هددت به اذا استمر الرئيس سعيد في مساره
لا هو الاتحاد العام تونسي للشغل قرارات
سياديه والقطاعات والنقابات تخو قراراتها
بمعزل على اي على سياسه اي حزب والا اي
قوه سياسيه في البلاد ما نجموشنتهم
الاتحاد هذا هذا الاتهام ولكن الازمه
شامله اليوم في البلاد واللي قاعدين
عايشينه من مظاهر لتدهور المرفق العام
وتراجع على كل المستويات الاجتماعيه
والاقتصاديه والسياسيه هو الذي دفع
التونسيين همم الى الخروج سواء من خلال
نقابات للاحتجاج على اوضاعهم القطاعيه
الصعبه او ايضا القوه السياسيه للاحتجاج
على التراجع الكبير الحاصل في مجال
الحريات وفي مجال الحقوق الانسان وعلى
المسار الديمقراطي بالتالي تعدد اوجه
الازمه هو الذي ولا ده هذه
المناطق المتفجره في البلاد في المنظمات
وفي الاحزاب وفي الشارع كما وفي مختلف في
ال- اا المواقع داخل البلاد لذلك عندما
نتحدث اليوم عن تحرك لقطاع النقل فان بحكم
وعايشتنا
للواقع التونسي نتوقع ان عديد القطاعات
الاخرى تعاني ايضا من ازمه همم رئيس
الدوله يحدثنا عن مفاهيم جديده وعن حوارات
باشكال جديده ولكن بعد سنه ونصف لم نرى
هذه المفاهيم الجديده ولا هذه الاشكال
الجديده للحوار
وكانه ليس له من هدف الا ان ينفرد بالحكم
بشكل احادي يحدد مسيره التونسيين
وخياراتهم من مستقبليه همم ويا ليته كان
يمتلك من الكفاءه وفريقه بما يجعلنا نخرج
من هذه الازمه التي نعيش طيب صحيح انه
اضراب نقاب لكن حتى ما يتحدث بالاتحاد همم
العام التونسي للشغل لا يفصله مطلقا عن
الازمه السياسيه في البلاد فالامين العام
اتحاد التونسي للشغل نور الدين الطبوبي
يحذر من ان تونس مقدما على ما سماه طوفان
اجتماعي الطبون بشدد على ان الازمه في
البلاد
التونسيه ازمه سياسيه بامتياز وقال ان
الاتحاد لم يطلق بعد مبادره ولكنه انطلق
في التشاور وتبادل الافكار الطبول قال ان
الهدف يبقى ايجاده مبادره لاخراج تونس من
الماءزق الذي ترد فيه وذكر ان التشاور
يبقى مفتوحا امام كل المنظمات الوطنيه
التي تتوفى فيها الاستقلاليه والقدره على
الاصبع بالحقيقه
اعود اليك سيد صبري
كلام نور الدين الطبوبي يؤكد ان المساله
لا تنفصل عن الجانب السياسي مطلقا لان
الازمه برمتها هي ازمه سياسيه لكن عندما
تحدث عن انه ليست هناك مبادره واضحه
وجاهزه هناك مجرد تبادل وتشاور همم
بالافكار ماذا يعني ذلك اليس لدى الاتحاد
اي رؤيه واضحه
للخروج من الازمه يمكن ان يطرحها على
الرئيس سعيد او على قياده سياسيه اخرى
وليست المره الاولى الاتحاد يطلق مبادرات
للدعوه للحوار الوطني بالمنظر يعني قبل 25
جويليه وبعد 25 هجري قدم ورقه كامله الى
رئيس الدوله وقتها قبل 25 شهيد باعتباره
يمثل المؤسسه الاكثر استقرارا وقتها
بالمقارنه مع مؤسسه البرلمان بعد 25 جوليا
وعندما تحسس الاتحاد خاصه
عندما وضع رئيس الدوله كل السلطات بين
يديه
وقدمت حول المساج من الحريات العامه
والفرديه من الحقوق الاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه وادعى الرئيس دائما الى
الحوار هذه المره المناظمه مقتنعه
بان عدم الاستقرار السياسي سيكون له
انعكاسات سلبيه على الوضع على الاقتصادي
والاجتماعي نشاهده اليوم في المشهد
السياسي من من منافسات ومن سرعات بالطبيعه
هل ستكون نهايه الكائن انعكاسات اقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه لذلك يسال عن الاتحاد عن تونس
الشغل اليوم بالدعوه الى حوار وطني هذه
المره صحيح انه هناك ملامسه لبعض الافكار
هل ستكون الصيغه صيغه الحوار مثل الصيغه
السابقه عندما فازت الاتحاد بجائزه نوبل
للسلام
المشاورات انطلقت همم يعني مع عماد محاميد
حقوق الانسان والمكونات المجتمع المدني
الاخرى
التي تتقاطع مع الاتحاد العام
الاخر همم هل الرئيس قيس سعيد هنا مستعد
ايضا للحوار وتبادل الافكار همم والرؤى
السيد قيصر الصياح الى اي مدى يمكن للرئيس
سعيد ان يدخل في حوار من جديد مع الاتحاد
العام التونسي للشغل الضوء الازمات
الاجتماعيه وتفاقومها
اولا رئيس جمهوريه كان بطبيعه الحال في
مناسبات عديده وكثيره الاول المستقبلين
للسيد نور الدين الطبوبي بقصر قرطاج وكان
مشاوره كثيره منذ سنه ونصف تقريبا السنه
ونصف اخيرا بعد كورونا وكان هناك تشاور
وكان حتى السيد لمين العام الاتحاد العام
التونسي الشغل وكدليل على التواصل منهجيه
الحوار على الاقل الجزء لاقول الحوار
الكامل الذي تريده الان يريد
تماما الوضع الان بين الاتحاد والرئيس
اصبح مختلفه جدا
واخر وصف للوضع الذي وصلت اليه تونس من
الاتحاد هو انه وضع متعفن يعني اختلفت
الصوره بالكامل
لا ليس صحيحا واقول هذا على مسؤوليتي
الخاصه الوضع بين رئيس الجمهوري والاتحاد
العام التونسي الشغل كمناظمه عريقه في
البلاد
وسهمت في كل المحطات والخطوات اللازمه
لتحرير دوله لم يكون ابدا متق ان هذا بدا
وله سياسي من طرف جامد معين من شقه
المعارضه ان مالك اتحاد الان ما اعيبه على
الوضع الموجود الان ان يستمع قليلا رئيس
الدوله على الاقل وان يلتجي الى حوار ولو
ابن صغر معه المنظمات العريقه التي سماها
بالمنظمات الغير الفاسده والتي من بين
العماد الوطنيه المحامين ومنظمه تونسيه
للشغل الاتحاد العام التونسي الشغل
حقوق الانسان على الاقل ما اطالب انا به
رئيس الجمهوريه واعتبره مطالبا جوهريا
وشكلا ان يقوم همم اولا بحوار مصغر
الوطنيه المحاميين ومنظم التمثيل الحقوق
الانسان للخروج
بالبلاد من هذا المنحرجه
ايجابيه من حينونه في الانزلاق الخفيف جدا
ولا في قديم الزمان طيب ارد في نقطه وحيده
امنه مجرد للقيام بالاغراض الان في هذا
التوقيت بالذات وهو عمل عبسي لان الاضراب
هو شكل من اشكال كسر العظام
وليد ذراع ويعرف الاتحاد جيدا لنظام
ولجمعه شتات والحوار امر غير منطقي وغير
معقول والزكاني في الدوله 600 مليار يوم
25 جرام الاتحاد
للاشاره فقط
او الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل كان وصفا
على الوضع العام في تونس ولم يقصد الوضع
بينه وبين الرئيس قيس سعيد فقط للتوضيح لن
ااه لم اقصد انه قال عن الوضع بينه وبين
الرئيس بل عن الوضع العام في تونس قال انه
همم متعفن همم هنا انتقل من جديد الى همم
السيد رياض الشعيبي سيد رياض هل بالامكان
اساسا هل بامكان المعارضه ان تتفق على
رؤيه همم همم واحده وهي المنقسمه على
نفسها اساسا خصوصا في ظل الحديث عن مبادره
قد يطلق على الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل
هل قادر المعارضه بكل اطيافها المختلفه ان
تتفق على خريطه طريق معينه او رؤيه معينه
للحوار او للخروج من المنزل
اولا همم
ولاحظ انه الدعوه للحوار دعوه الرئيس
الدوله للحوار هي دعوه اا جاءت خليل
القران في وقت همم لا اعتقد انه ما زال
هناك من يؤمن في تونس بانه هذا الرئيس له
الاستعداد لان يتحاور مع اي طرف من
الاطراف وبالتالي كل دعوه للحوار كل دعوه
وجه لرئيس الدوله للحوار اعتقد انها لن
تكون لن يكون لها جدوى وليس هناك من حل
الان سواء الذهاب لانتخابات رئاسيه مبكرا
لحل هذه الازمه الدستوريه والسياسيه
والاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه التي تعيش البلاد
ثاني ينهى للمعارضه متفقه التطورات التي
تحصل في الواقع تؤشر بوضوح على هذا
التقارب بين مختلف الاحزاب السياسيه
والقوه السياسيه وحتى بعض القوى
الاجتماعيه حول هذه الرؤيه حول اننا ان
البلاد تحتاج الى تغيير همم هذا التغيير
من العمق بمكان من الاهميه الى تغيير هذا
تغيير هذا التغيير هذا التغيير لن يحصل
يعني لا نريد ان نتحدث عن امور الان غير
واقعيا هذا التغيير وانتخابات رئاسيه
مبكره وغير ذلك في ضوء المواقف الاقليميه
والدوليه وفي ضوء ما يجري في تونس هذا
الامر غير مس- او بالاحرى مستعد الان ماذا
بامكان المعارضه ان تفعل والى اين سيتجه
الوضع في تونس في ضوء المعطيات المتوفره
حاليا على الارض تفضل
لا نحن لا نقول هذا الكلام ولا اتفق معك
في هذا الاستخلاص نحن نعتبر انه مطلب
الانتخابات الرئاسيه هو مطلب واقعي واننا
نظلنا في ويل سنه ونصف ومازلنا مستمرين في
هذا المسار حتى الوصول لتحقيق هذا الهدف
السياسي وبالتالي خطتنا النداليه القادمه
شعارها وعنوان الاهم هو الضغط من اجل
الذهاب لانتخابات رئاسيه مبكره نحن نعتقد
انه الشارع السياسي يتوسع باستمرار والقوه
السياسيه يترسخ لديها القناعه اكثر بان
هذا هو الحل وهذا ما تعبر عنه كل
المبادرات التي نسمعها الان سواء من
شخصيات مستقله او من احزان سياسيه او ربما
ايضا دعوه جبهه الخلاص لان يتولى قاضي
مرحرح الانتقاليه تمهد لانتخابات الرئاسيه
المبكر وبالتالي هناك ما يشبه الاتفاق
الواسع داخل القوه السياسيه على ان هذه
المرحله يجب ان تنتهي باسرع ما يمكن ويجب
ان ننتقل باسلوب سياسي واسلوب ديمقراطي
على جديده نستعيد ونستاذن فيها القيام
والمبادئ الديمقراطيه شكرا لك رياض
الشعيبي من تونس عضو الهيئه التنفيذيه
لجبهه الخلاص وشكرا لصبريز غيدي الصحفي
بجريده الشعب التابعه للاتحاد العام
التونسي للشغل وايضا الشكر موصول لقيصر
الصياح المحامي والباحث في القانون كما
معنى منسوسه شرقي يونس
انتهت حلقتنا من برنامج ما وراء الخبر الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]